mais mme de grandmaison ce livre que
vous venez de publier
c'est pourquoi exactement c'est parce
que vous aviez envie de faire un bilan
mais c'est peut-être quelque chose qui
pourrait sonner comme le coup d'envoi
d'une nouvelle aventure
non il n'y a pas de nouvelles aventures
il ya le temps du bilan il ya le temps
de l'action et a le temps du bilan il ya
le temps de la transmission et c'est de
ça qu'il s'agit
nous sommes un pays en plein plein je ne
dirais pas blocage de développement il
faut que chacun apporte sa pierre mas
pierre le peut-être que rendu des
expériences menées quand je crois
intéressante les accueillant ce qui nous
qui ont abouti qui ont été temporaire
puisque ça ne s'est pas prolongée dans
le temps mais des expériences qui valent
parce qu'en fait toutes les expériences
que j'ai tenté sont devenus des clés de
développement développement durable
développement endogène prises l
environnement culture socle du
développement
et bien tout ça c'est ça et nous sommes
une île avec toute sa diversité
toutes ces beautés ses doigts ça qu'il
nous faut vivre votre terre est fertile
notre volcan est attractif par
conséquent nous devons pratiquement
commuée le malheur en le projet d'avenir
ce malheur peut-être la sortie de l'
esclavage ce malgré peut-être l'éruption
de la montagne pelée ce malheur
peut-être tout ça et surtout aux joues
dont j'oublie le malheur c'est la fuite
de nos cerveaux un bain il nous faut
comme nous tous a en projet d'avenir et
c'est ça mon livre un élément une pierre
apportée à ça alors dans ce livre il ya
également un vrai discours politique
profond de conviction c'est que le nord
est le nord n'est pas seulement un
grenier sa mort d'êtres véritable pôle
de développement touristique en commun
tout à fait est d'autant que l'heure
n'est même plus au grenier à l'heure
actuelle ces terres sont largement
friche ses terres on n'a pas encore
trouvé quoi mettre dessus par rapport à
des toxiques à une intoxication durée
non là donc mais il ya des choses à
faire sous ce nom parce que même sous
une terre pleine de chlordécone
soumettant pied au cours
ça nous passe le chlordécone situe
mettre les oranges et ça me parle
si tu mets des citrons ça ne monte pas
et ça évite d'en acheter à en bolivie en
colombie et en israël
et partout dans le monde donc il faut se
mettre au travail
la terre est là il faut adresser tous
ces les derniers mots de mon livre
paroles d'honneur voyez la terre l'eau
dirigeait tour homme comme tout en main
voilà la question
alors la dernière question mais puisque
il y a eu des expériences d'écriture
convergence touristes et puis tout cela
est finalement tombé en désuétude
pourquoi parce que précisément j'ai dit
le roi nain politique n'a pas de débris
le soutien des gens du terrain les
responsables du terrain ils se sont
fatigués en 81 99 dans un dans un dans
un comme on disait au colloque au
leyritz on a demandé aux responsables au
plus haut rang et jamel alors et la
population et la boue les yeux qu'est ce
que vous allez faire vous nous nous
avons l'impression d'être laissés pour
compte
ah ben on a des gens n'ont pas répondu à
l angoisse et le nom est resté tel qu'il
est mais je dis également dans cet
ouvrage que le nord mais pas une île
dans la martinique et c'est pour ça que
j'ai intitulé le livre une voie pour le
lot mon terroir et la martinique mon
pays parce que ma vision élargie à la
matinée et cet élargissement consiste à
1 à à mettre en place un projet global
dans lequel le nord était serré le sud
est est tiré d'un aux caraïbes le voyais
des pôles de développement et à ce
moment là tu un projet global dans
lequel chacun trouve sa place